I've got some video to play for you
today that is nothing short of tragic
Donald Trump had this unhinged Magga
rally in Ohio last week it was riddled
with lies attacks on political opponents
smears blaming everybody else for
failures taking credit for successes
that don't even have anything to do with
him and that was the rally itself but I
found a video posted on Twitter
yesterday of an eight-year-old being
interviewed at rumpus eight-year-old
being interviewed which reminded me of a
horrible video I once saw of a
brainwashed Argentinian kid talking
politics although this kid at the Trump
rally was far less articulate than that
Argentinian one anyway I'm looking for
information about the guy who's doing
the interview who seems to be some kind
of Christian pastor you'll see him going
to prayer he at one point puts his hand
on the kid's head to pray for him so
let's look at the first part of the clip
my question to you is is this child
abuse are the circumstances that got
this kid to this mental state by the
parents that is our is that child abuse
because an 8 year old doesn't become
like this on their own and again you'll
notice if you're watching that the
moment the kid says something about
Trump being great or whatever the pastor
puts his hand on the kid's head and
starts praying this is full
indoctrination on a political front on a
religious front that this is crazy take
a look right over here get out of the
way of the folks coming up here what's
your name okay say that again
okay beau gray what are you doing out
here
my mom and pop are sitting here cause
you just reminded me of my daughter when
you said that your naina and Popeye god
bless you lord I just pray a special
blessing tell me it bow is it bow I pray
a special blessing on bow lord I pray
that you would bless and keep him you'd
make it your face to shine upon him be
gracious unto him raise them up Lord
into the warrior that you happen to be
let this light shine out of this young
man what I pray in any of the darkness
that wants to come Lord that your light
would just shine through it I'm glad to
meet you Bo and I'm glad that your papa
and that is it Nana Nana and your pop on
your name they brought you out here I go
to school Elementary now this isn't
about this kid I want to be clear this
kid is a victim the kid doesn't see
himself as a victim the parents don't
see him as a victim this Christian
pastor dude who puts his hand on the
kid's head clearly they don't see the
kid as a victim but what happens when
this kid enters the real world okay what
happens if this kid goes to college if
that's something that's in the kids
future this kid's parents are the ones
who likely say college is just liberal
indoctrination because look at who
they're raising who will eventually
maybe arrive at college and be
completely unprepared for how the real
world actually works there's more video
let's watch a little bit more that is so
cool and did you get to get out of
school today to come see the president
yes
it's so your mom checked you out of
school that didn't hurt your feelings
though did it first time to see how
excited are you on a scale of one so
when he comes out on that stage are you
just gonna be going crazy anything else
you want to see do you play football I
see the football shirt it's such an
honor to meet you young man
and shout out to your mom god bless ya
all right that's great let's screenshot
this hang on there's even a little bit
more but let's stop it there
notice that the kids said when Donald
Trump became the first president might
have misspoken also what what might of
his parents been telling him to come up
with that idea this seems like a news
report characterized in like a dystopian
alternate universe science fiction movie
where everything has gone wrong right
this is like oh you know in a
time-travel film where someone came back
and did something that modified a future
universe and things went completely off
the rails this is how it would be
depicted remember that the American
right says that they're worried about
the left indoctrinating children look at
this video and as I mentioned this
reminded me of an argentinian kid named
casey wonder who's way more articulate
than this kid but just as indoctrinated
without really having a clue i'm not
gonna play it for you because of
copyright issues with our gen Tinian
news stations but if you go on youtube
and you just type in casey wonder you'll
find an interview with this kid and the
subtitles i think will may be translated
subtitles will help you figure out
what's going on we wonder why we're
falling behind in math and science and
then we see that this kid instead of
being in school he said
Trump rally with his sycophant parents
being celebrated by the people around
him including being prayed for by
another irrational trump supporter all
of whom believe that Donald Trump is a
pseudo deity of some kind and I know
that many of our instincts when we see
this our instincts are just discussed oh
this is disgusting but this connects to
really serious things that have happened
in the Midwest and in other regions of
the country that got us to where we are
today because this is not merely
cultural this is not merely about
intelligence this is not merely about
religion it's very easy for you know
people in liberal parts of the country
to see this and to just laugh and to say
we're superior look at this backward
stuff this is the end result of a
combination of growing inequality as the
rich get more and more rich and the poor
get less and less alongside the
convenient demonization of what is
essentially modernity under the guise of
they want to indoctrinate you in college
and in those liberal cities like New
York and Boston and what's interesting
is that similar economic circumstances
in northeastern blue states have
generated progressive activists around
issues like education and other issues
in the Midwest and in other areas those
same economic problems although those
problems exist to a greater degree in
red states as we've talked about have
produced people who have gone into this
hyper religious conservative shell
they've become voters along the issues
of abortion and religion and guns and
it's very easy for us and it's very
tempting for us to watch this and pass
judgment on it but that's part of why we
lost in 2016 and we will lose again in
2020 if we just write this stuff off
okay even if we are logically correct
when we say children raised in an
open-minded Massachusetts family will be
better off in the real world than this
kid that may well be true but it ignores
the reality of how things got this way
and what it will take to change them and
that is the really important thing we
can't forget going into 2020 by the way
if
this video is a parody and I'm just
missing it please tell me I'd be
relieved to hear that this video is
merely a parody if you have information
about who that dude is praying over this
kid touching his head I do want to know
because it it reeks of all of the worst
of what we are fighting against but
again if we just pass judgment on it
that's not going to help us win I want
to tell you about a really great YouTube
channel we're partnering with it's
called up flip TV and they've just
recently launched they've have some
excellent content for anybody interested
in business and entrepreneurship check
them out at david pakman.com slash flip
that's f li p
that'll redirect you to their youtube
channel make sure to subscribe while
you're there it is a YouTube channel
that I'd recommend to anyone in the
David Pakman show audience who owns a
business runs a business is thinking
about starting a business or even if you
just like learning new things about how
business works they interview successful
entrepreneurs business owners giving
them a place to tell their stories and
share strategies so viewers can benefit
from their insight and apply their
wisdom to your own businesses all of the
content is about educating and inspiring
people in each video up flip TV
showcases a different type of startup it
could be a coffee shop or a landscaping
business or a real estate agency you'll
see how the business was often started
from scratch what a workday looks like
how to become and remain successful in
that business and they don't just
interview people they actually examine
each business from inside out in a
really unique way that distills the
valuable lessons that you can take from
their stories I find the content
fascinating they're friends of the David
Pakman show I would love it if you would
go and support their new YouTube channel
and what they're doing I think you'll
very quickly become a fan like I said
get there by going to david pakman.com
slash flip that's FL IP and make sure to
subscribe to their channel when you're
there